[Music]
welcome back to the proposed waimakariri
district e-plan if you haven't already
watched how to use our e-plan video we
recommend watching this first you can
find it on our website
to make a submission on the proposed
district plan you need to be registered
to register click the submissions button
on the home screen
a pop-up screen will appear select
register
fill in your email address create a
password and click
register
if you don't have an email address
contact the council to discuss your
options
you'll then get an email from us to
confirm your details
make sure to click the link to verify
and activate your account
you can now make a submission in one of
two ways
to make a submission via the submissions
portal click submissions on the home
screen and log in
click new submission at the top right of
the screen then click
make a submission
enter your details you only have to do
this once
next name your submission and answer the
qualifying questions including whether
you want to be heard in support of your
submission at a hearing
once you're ready to make your
submission click new submission point
from here select the section
subsection
and provision you want to comment on
and select whether you oppose
support
or support in part
add your feedback in the text box
you can also add attachments like
evidence or supporting documents to your
comment
finally save your submission
[Music]
you can make as many submission points
as you like before submitting your
feedback at the bottom right of the
screen
you can also edit your submission points
before submitting
you can also make a submission while
looking up your property
first search for your property
[Music]
then click make submission in the menu
on the left hand side of the screen
you may be asked to log in with the
details you provided earlier or if you
haven't made an account you can do this
now
click on the provisions in the e-plan
that you want to provide feedback on
fill in your comments
making sure you complete both tabs
and click done
it will save your feedback as you scroll
through the chapters and provisions
relating to your property
to submit your feedback click the edit
submit submission link at the top of the
screen
you'll then see a list of all the
provisions you commented on you can view
and edit these and add more comments if
you wish
once you're ready click submit
thanks for taking an interest in the
district plan
if you're having any trouble using the
e-plan try reading our comprehensive
step-by-step guide at
waimakariri.govt dot nz forward slash
let's talk